I'm delighted to welcome you to the podium,
Frances West.
Good morning.
Um,
I want to thank Sarah for that introduction.
Uh,
I also know Sarah from the past and it's great to see a collie and I'm at Google
and that this is a very
exciting day for me personally.
Like Sarah said,
I spend quite a few years in IBM and my last job was a IBM's two vessels to be
the officer.
Um,
but now I have my own consulting company because my last job actually was
probably the most meaningful job I ever had at IBM.
I,
um,
I came to this topic about,
human centric,
um,
technology impact on Sosa,
future society.
Uh,
in my last job because I spend my entire years in IBM in the first two third of
my lives really learning about technology,
selling technology and market technology.
And I'm just not until my last job in IBM research where my organization was,
um,
located that I realize this fundamental concept of diversity really brings
disruptive innovation.
And many of you
in this audience or outside in this attack community know that the topic of
inclusion is a very,
very big topic.
Right?
And uh,
but when it comes down to it,
what I realize is that inclusion in many cases,
at least in today's environment,
a lot of times the cast as more of a HR human resource initiative and a lot of
people talk about inclusion as a kind of um,
consistent what we call the constituency topic,
you know,
gender,
race,
um,
and so on or religion.
But the way I look at diversity is that it really brings to bear the heart of
innovation.
And let me just give you a little bit of a history of by myself and give you a
little bit of a journey of my personal kind of a growth in this area.
And they share with you why I believe that diversity is the core of it.
Disruptive Innovation.
I was in the United States three years with the kind of a broken English.
I went to a campus interview in Lexington,
Lexington,
Kentucky with a manager by the name of frank fruit or sort just based on that
name,
you can tell that it's kind of a German descent,
um,
name.
And at that time I only had waitressing in a Chinese restaurant as my
experience.
Um,
I sit down in front of this frankly Frank Frazier,
store manager for IBM and gave him what I thought my Chinese waitressing job
will bring to my understanding of customer service.
At the end of a one hour interview,
he said to me,
Francis or then he asked me the very crucial question,
do you have a green card or permanent residency?
I'm like,
no,
I don't,
but I am going to marry while my brother caught a foreign devil.
Oh,
by the way,
that's why I have a last name or west,
far from being released.
Um,
so I said to him,
I'm going to get a,
I'm going to marry a foreign dev or I didn't say that I,
I'm going to meet her American,
I'm going to get my citizenship.
And then so he said,
great,
Francis,
go get married.
Have a nice honeymoon,
you have a job with IBM.
So this gentleman,
frank store was the first person you might life that really practice what I call
authentic inclusion in the sense that
I hardly know English.
I didn't have a green card and yet he believed in me or what I could become.
I didn't even know what I could do at that time.
Anyway,
that's how I started IBM career.
Um,
in the next 20 some years.
I help IBM.
So a cell mainframe for those of you who don't know what mainframe is,
anybody watched the,
uh,
the movie hidden figures.
Okay,
that's a mainframe.
We worked on technology to put people out in the moon.
We were down technology builder,
the American airline Saber system,
which you still use today for a airline reservation.
We build a system for social security administration.
So at that time the technology was all about,
um,
putting what we call the,
uh,
infrastructure system or business system to be more effective,
to be more efficient.
And I remember back then,
the keyword as a systems engineer,
I was trained to think about on behalf of the customer are three keywords,
Ras,
Ras stands for reliability,
availability and serviceability.
So that was an era where the computer is all about system an optimization.
And because of that,
uh,
kind of a knowledge and also,
um,
a background.
I,
I actually had the opportunity to be the first wave of IBM was the go to China
in the mid nineties.
And one of my,
I was still say my biggest accomplishment was actually helping the Chinese
government to build the China payment system,
which is the federal reserve equivalent of Interbank Clarence system.
So we're talking about big system handling,
uh,
at the beginning of the check processing and then what we call the payment
infrastructure.
So all these are very exciting,
you know,
um,
learning a profession,
a professional growth and all that.
And then I came back from a Chinese China assignment in the early 2000 I had the
opportunity to join IBM research to help this organization call IBM human
ability and assessability center.
And frankly,
I knew very little about accessibility.
How many of you here know about assessability?
Okay,
so for those of you who don't know us as ability in the technical world or the
the technology or definition,
it's about,
think of it in the ultimate objectivist has ability is about digital inclusion.
Meaning you want to make sure that the technology solution or product or apps
that you put out there,
that every human being on this planet can use it.
Not just some,
but all right.
When I say all I mean means people who are aging or people who has disabilities,
that disability can be vicious.
Unrelated,
could be hearing related,
could be mobile mobility related,
and most important,
it could be cognitive,
unrelated.
So part of the job and the mission of our organization was to make sure that
everything coming out of IBM at the time is as assessable as possible,
first and foremost to our employees.
And then won't,
because we want to eat your own dog food.
Once we make sure that our employee,
you can be productive.
Actually,
uh,
earlier you were saying it was,
um,
is a equity engineering.
That's exactly the kind of a goal that we're striving for,
which is there is parody and equity of everybody will come to work.
And then we learned a lot about that process and then,
uh,
and then was able to help our customer to become more accessible.
So in that job,
I thought for sure that I will do it for three years,
which is kind of a track record.
I had IBM at the time because you want to move on,
you want to get promoted.
And even in big company I'm showing Google,
you know,
you want to try different things,
um,
to,
to widen your experience.
Little did I know that that became,
started out to be a job,
then became a career and then become a calling because for the first time I
realized of all the Glamor I got from selling big systems to Chinese government
and,
and installing,
um,
cat cam system with Raytheon pair,
you know,
cannot compare to the satisfaction I got when I worked with a person with
disabilities.
And to see that how he or she can perform at work with the same kind of
enthusiasm and productivity.
So that is the essence of what this,
what the disability center was about.
And from there we really led the innovation.
Why?
Because our staff inside IBM research,
we actually have people with disabilities,
we have blind engineer,
we have deaf scientists innovating and creating new solutions because every
single day they have to deal with issues or challenges.
And in many cases their perspective is so creative is so out of the box thinking
that it just create a,
what we call the disruptive kind of innovation.
So that is what I personally not only saw what he experienced and uh,
after working in this capacity and that became IBM chief accessibility officer.
It is around 2016 timeframe and that we all know around 2016,
frankly,
that was the beginning was a lot of uh,
talk about,
for example,
the silicon valley diversity issues.
Right.
And,
um,
and like I said personally,
because my own journey I had the opportunity to experience one would say because
I am at this point you probably know,
can tell I am first generation non English speaking Chinese and woman in tech
and also age over age 50.
So I kind of checked the box of every inclusion criteria.
So
just like the state farm insurance commercial,
we know a few because we have seen a few.
So for my personal perspective I felt like there is a tremendous amount of um,
story needs to be told to really put the inclusion not just as an HR kind of uh,
a perspective.
It's not just about hiring but it's about innovation and that we are at the
critical point in our history of technology that company like Google is Google.
You guys are in the forefront of a technology innovation,
really have to think about this topic very,
very seriously and that you really have the capacity and also to a large extent,
you're a responsibility to make sure the technology innovation from this point
on and go,
you forward has all human needs and all human wants into consideration.
Now why do I say that?
So earlier I talked about in my era of a computer or technology,
we were focusing on system optimization where four kids down,
like I said,
reliability,
service,
a availability and service,
Avila B.
But in the past 10,
15 years,
we all know that the technology has moved from a system optimization model to a
personal optimization or personally experienced model.
We're beginning to see the trend is especially the emergence of the mobile,
right?
When mobile came onto the scene,
I remember before mobile devices become prevalent to talk about accessibility
was a very difficult topic.
You know,
you go up to a,
you know,
25 year old,
um,
fresh college Grad and you say you need to think about people who are aging
somehow.
It just doesn't quite resonate,
right.
Cause they just want to code.
They want to get things out.
They weren't,
they weren't fancy,
um,
kind of a screen experience,
you know,
everything kind of a,
a flash and,
and fly in and all that.
They don't think about how cognitively,
kind of a confusing it could be for a person with disabilities or aging.
But when the mobile phone came along,
you know,
when I started talking to people and say,
you know what,
the font size matters often people,
right?
Yeah.
You know,
when it was too small,
fallen like size 11 or 12,
I cannot see on my cell phone color contrast.
When you send in the song,
if you don't have enough color contrast,
you won't be able to read when you are on the go because mobile and now and oh
well all the work,
uh,
everybody to be on the girl when you're at the airport,
you know when you're listening on that conference call and there's a lot of
ambient noise you cannot here,
wouldn't it be nice if you have captioning?
So all of a sudden,
all these fundamental assessability or human centric technology requirement
becomes universally relevant because every one of us could have temporarily,
or what I call situationally disabled.
So with the technology coming into what I call the personalized experience and
Google,
you guys actually lead some of the effort with a,
your android platform and also your search engine affects every single person on
the planet.
I just saw a news that Google is trying to reenter China market.
So that's another one,
1.6 billion people,
one quarter of the,
uh,
of the population on earth.
Or by the way,
do you know,
for example,
I talked about aging.
Do you know that China by 20,
by 2025,
we'll have over 360 million people over age 65.
That's the entire population in the United States.
I was just in China in March and I was invited to speak as the only,
kind of a outside speaker,
um,
to the Chinese companies like Alibaba,
Baidu,
and Tencent on the topic of assessability.
Now.
Why would China talk about accessibility today in the United States?
If you are progressive thinking companies like Google,
like IBM in this case,
Microsoft recently have done a lot of working assessability area,
then you think about us as ability,
not as a compliance topic by lot of companies today,
because United States a litigious society and because we have American
disability act,
lot of technologists,
their first experience with accessibility is a tie to ada section 508
compliance.
How many of you know of the legislation of Ada that apply to digital as
disability?
Not many.
Let me tell you,
this is a trend and this is phenomenon that's not going to go away.
So in the United States,
if you are a government procurement company,
which I think Google is,
right?
If you want a big federal government business like department,
Department of Defense or NASA or a social security or veterans affair,
if you want to be a federal contractor,
you must prove that your product is assessable.
European Union just passed a similar law.
China has the same procurement law in the baking's,
so out of 146 countries in the world who signed the UN Convention on the rights
of people disability,
which was a PSAP establish a two oh six people would tell you this human rights
convention of un,
it's equivalent.
The importance is equivalent to the Kyoto Treaty on the green movement.
United States actually let the entire effort of human rights as we are,
I think we can agree and Ada American disability.
I actually set the goal standard for digital accessibility,
but the fact that a we are not a member of UN convention over time is going to
erode our leadership.
Why do I know that?
I was very fortunate to represent the entire it industry to testify in front of
the u s Senate on this particular topic and it breaks my heart that we weren't
able to get the United States Congress.
We were six votes short in getting this ratified as other hundred 46 countries,
but that said,
the digital inclusion standards and digital inclusion future at this point is
still set by the u s company like Google.
Like Facebook,
like apple.
And that's one of the reason why this topic is so important because from this
point on,
we all know that technology is not just system optimization effects every single
person on this planet.
And when I say every single person,
I mean,
and I don't mean the w the 1% or the 10%,
I mean the entire stack including the base of the pyramid.
So
in this today's kind of a,
an equivalent of what I said,
there are the Ras for the mainstream and my a mainframe computers today we
should be talking about and we are talking about for example,
um,
kind of a computer impact in the terms of privacy,
right?
Security.
Cause these affects every person.
And I will argue that assessability should be part of that discussion.
So therefore it's Psa,
privacy,
security and accessibility.
Because if you truly a view believe that your solution,
whether you are a programmer,
your engineer,
your designer,
whatever you're making,
if you want that product or services or solution or apps to be made available to
every human being and you should have every human being as your objective,
then you have to think human centric.
You have to think,
what can I do on a day to day basis to make this a reality?
A lot of people talk about inclusion and they will say,
this is a topic.
The management,
you know at the top should set the Sanders,
set the leadership.
And like I said,
for my experience,
inclusion is everybody's responsibility is specially when it comes down to
digital inclusion.
Because if you go around,
he asked people and say,
do you believe that everybody should be equal?
Everybody will say,
of course.
And if you go around and say,
do you want your product to be only available to some people?
Not all people,
everybody was saying no.
So principally everybody agree that this is the right thing to do.
But when it comes into practice,
people will say,
I'll average,
believe me,
I've heard all kinds of excuses.
Oh my budget is,
is,
is does not allow me to do this or is not part of our department's priority.
So there are all kinds of potential obstacle put in front of you.
But on the other hand,
as an individual,
you actually can make a difference.
You can actually be the person,
make a conscious decision whether this is the authentic inclusion decision
you're going to make as you go about your daily business.
So this is one of the kind of a principal I'm thinking about authentic inclusion
that I would like to share with you and that at this,
again,
in this particular time,
all of us,
you know,
have this kind of responsibility,
especially in the technology area,
because technology is going to be,
it's not going to be,
it's already pervasive in every person's life.
And can you imagine if your technology has quan call embedded,
you know,
discriminatory kind of a feature or function,
not by design,
not by intention,
what,
by lack of attention that could happen.
So this is really what we're talking about is that how can a company like Google
and how can the individual as a Googler you along with other technology
companies together in calming to understand the impact of your behavior and your
action on a day to day basis and the how a company can enable you all to do
this.
And the final point I want to make is that this is a topic that really goes
beyond what we call the inclusion.
This is a topic about putting human first,
putting human in the middle of all your thinking.
And as you design,
as you think about everything,
and it's also not a just an idea,
but as an institution,
if you are a manager,
you actually have the capability to what I call institutionalize the thinking.
When I was at IBM,
we actually take this topic and then make it a very,
in that we have design camps,
we have,
you know,
um,
development,
agile,
our processes.
We have a communication from our marketing department involved in this because
this has to be a kind of a central nucleus of accompanies the Ethel to believe
in that you as an individual and all also you as a company in the technology
forefront can impact the society and can also do the kind of equity computing
like we were talking about earlier.
So this is really the foundational of the,
of the thinking.
And I can share a lot of the kind of an institutional practice examples,
but I,
at this point,
you know,
with this audience and perhaps I can open up for questions and then we can't
have a more of a dialogue instead of me,
you know,
giving you more of a kind of a,
um,
a practice perspective.
So any,
uh,
any question that you may have.
Yes.
So designing a product for like the whole spectrum of populations is really
hard.
So to you all it,
does IBM have any framework that could help people make
that happened?
Well,
the,
we actually have what we call the design language and thinking,
and one of the things that I actually wanted to talk about,
it's very hard to do as ability to by itself because you have separate that al.
This seems to be extra effort.
So what we did is that we work with our design team and got a lot of the concept
built into the design thinking.
I mean,
Google must have a standard design
process.
No.
When your product comes out,
do you go through certain kind of um,
testing and,
and,
and all that.
Okay.
Yes sir.
Well,
maybe over time,
maybe this is something you used to think about,
right?
I mean,
so what we did is that a four,
um,
we know that Harway remember in our case we have hardware developers,
we have software developer will have services.
So it's very diverse portfolio.
But what we did is we kind of create a functional guidance,
think of it as a checklist.
So as any a developer go through what we call the concept design a plan and
design and implement stage.
We have a checklist for people to kind of use as a guidance is started out to be
a paper checklist.
And then,
um,
then we move on to automated checklist and now frankly we're using AI and based
on what the person's creating,
we actually can have AI to give,
um,
kind of prompters and oh,
by the way,
all of these are based on standards,
right?
Earlier I talked about his disability.
This is another thing as disability is not kind of a liberal left weighing kind
of a philosophy in the digital technology,
digital inclusion space.
This is actually a highly disciplined and regimented space in that we have
standards call wet cat 2.0 or it stands for a web accessibility accessibility
guideline,
which is came out of a w three c,
you know,
a worldwide web standards group.
So these are published standards that,
remember I mentioned 146 countries.
Every country is in the process adopting that standard.
Just like today in the telco world,
everybody's moving to five g for example,
right?
There is a certain certain sets of,
uh,
of a technology standards.
So between worldwide web,
between Itu,
between these global ISO standards,
there's there assessability center just like privacy standard and the security
standards that are,
are,
are coming together.
So again,
Google as a leader in this kind of technology,
you all actually have the capability to be a leader in terms of,
for example,
maybe using your artificial intelligence capability to integrate all these
elements into um,
into maybe a AI AI based tool to,
to lessen the burden of developers.
Does that make sense?
So that's to some degree also,
um,
the what,
what I mean by authentic inclusion framework that is inclusion should not just
be a buzz word or a statement or an idea.
You can and you should have organization constructs such as,
you know,
design criterias such as development standards such as testing protocols.
Another thing that our,
I don't know whether Google does or not,
but if you don't,
I highly recommend it,
is that you actually have people with,
for example,
cognitive challenge or vision challenge as part of your testing team.
Nothing like a real user that will humble you and also give you potentially out
of the box thinking.
And also a solution.
Like I mentioned,
I was in,
in China in March.
Um,
China actually just started the assessability journey less than 10 years ago.
So at that time I actually help translate Chinese or the word accessibility into
Chinese because the Chinese,
the Astra is my native language.
So 10 years ago,
you're looking at a country,
deny,
even have the word assessability
10 years now,
when I went back in March,
it was a,
uh,
forum sharing best practices from Baidu,
Tencent,
Alibaba,
and the most impressive and financial anybody heard of and financial
and the financial is part of Ali Baba.
Everybody know Ali Baba?
Okay?
So,
and financial,
think of it as Adi.
Everybody know Ali pay.
Ali Pay was equivalent to apple pay,
right?
So Ali Baba has created this entire ecommerce platform with a payment system.
And financial is their mobile fintech platform.
So if you Google,
if you Google and financial there in the press every day,
some people would be saying some Fintech,
you know,
Fintech,
financial technology is going to huge,
huge transformation.
And a lot of banks,
you know,
are actually worry about their existence 10 years from now.
Right.
Cause you got all the disruptors,
new type of a fintech companies coming in.
So in financial actually had,
um,
when they announced her,
uh,
a mobile APP was,
was,
is inaccessible.
So somebody complained,
does a social media network is very,
very strong in China as well because everybody has a mobile phone.
So what happened was that a kind of a went viral.
So what did an do in a financial,
do they immediately hired,
um,
a team,
a person with disabilities,
blindness,
aging and all that and made them a permanent part of their design team and also
their testing team?
No.
Again,
in China,
they don't have any laws.
They don't have Ada,
they don't,
they don't have anything to say.
You must do this.
But as a company,
I mean China Rhinos.
So consumer driven is unbelievable.
Talk about a focus on customer experience.
So the best practice there was shared by an financial,
it's the entire,
what we call the customer journey end to end and how they're embedding user
experience.
In this case,
particularly aging people with disability into the entire process.
And I remember sitting,
I'll stage,
I remember I was the only outside quote unquote expert and when I was listening
to them like,
oh my God,
they are like not only they get it,
they are actually surpassing frankly a lot of the companies doing here in the
United States.
So reason I'm sharing this with you is because this is not your father's
assessability topic anymore.
This is not about just making compliance and making Ada,
you know,
so Google can uh,
can,
can be a less a federal government contractor.
That's me minimum.
I'm here to talk to you about this is if you believe that everybody's going to
use technology,
you know,
like mobile fall as part of their living as part of their working as part of
their plane,
it's every single activity that human does is going to involve technology.
Then you must think of accessibility as part of that experience because
ultimately accessibility is about extreme personalization.
It's not that that person's disabled,
it's just my eyesight is not that good.
Especially when I'm driving.
You're not supposed to look at your phone,
but you still have emailed and things coming in.
At that point I would like my screen voice over to come on,
just talk to me.
Right?
So this is becoming,
think of it as a personal preference.
Again,
put the human first thinking cap on and don't think of this as meetings are
minimum,
you know,
compliance.
But think about how can I make my product,
my services?
How can I make the company Google to be the human first company that I think
about the human experience.
And then I'd build,
you know,
things around that human experience.
I built it for the human experience and that is to me a true leaders,
um,
action.
And if you do so then all the other things including inclusion we'll come about
naturally organically than you are now going out to hire a woman because you're
supposed to hire a woman.
You're not out hiring a,
a blind person because you are supposed to hire person disability and so on and
so forth.
Because what you believe fundamentally then is that technology's here to stay,
not only here to stay,
technology is going to be an integral part of every human exist existence.
I mean,
we didn't talk about Ai,
artificial intelligence and all that,
but if you start carry on,
you know,
do extrapolation where the technology's going,
it's going to be everything we do in everything we think was that I have the
opportunity to be at the conference in San Paulo,
Brazil with Vint cerf your own right then.
And I were talking about jobs of the future.
He certainly,
man invented the Internet.
So he talked about how he view,
you all know vins vision now is this people centered Internet,
right?
So Internet fall,
his perspective has kind of gone away from the original purpose of serving
people too.
So he's having this Pci people center,
Internet kind of.
Um,
Vishen and I'm coming in from my,
my kind of VA,
uh,
pragmatic,
um,
operational,
uh,
experience in managing Ibm's,
his abilities,
um,
organization and seeing how by thinking human first and by people having
diversity on my team and also throughout the IBM design team,
Ibm Development Team,
how that actually differentiated us as a company in terms of a product and
services and most importantly a culture.
Right?
It's because I w I would tell you that I would say the last point I want to make
is that
one of the things I always,
uh,
when I,
when I was a,
um,
on that,
on that day and was sharing is that everybody in the technology business is
about innovation.
We all know that if you don't have any innovation,
you die.
I mean,
he's just fact facts of life,
right?
So how do you make sure you have continuous innovation that's transformative,
that's disruptive,
right?
And if you look at history of a company right now,
Ibm I think is the only company that has over a hundred years of reinventing
itself.
Then you pew bag,
you said,
what is the secret sauce?
What is the thing that's make this company at least so far sustain,
you know,
wave and wave is of a,
of innovation fundamentally is this believe in diversity.
So Google,
you are in the tech world,
the undisputed leader.
And so therefore as a company actually Google along with you know,
um,
uh,
Microsoft and apple,
all the technology company,
we owe it to the world frankly to kind of not only promote but deliver some of
the fundamental promise of technology,
which is technology supposed to equalize access.
Technologist supposed to create a democracy and technology should have a
purpose.
And that's what we all have as the opportunity in front of us.
And that's why when Sarah told me that I,
that there,
you know,
there's an opportunity to speak at Google,
I jump at it right away because I sincerely believe that in this particular
timing,
our history,
if you look around whether the political system,
you cannot make system,
societal system,
everything seems to be an upheaval.
And we technologist have a responsibility,
use what we know on a day to day basis to better this world.
And one are the way to better the world is to make sure that we're not just
doing technology for technology's sake,
but always keep humans first as part of your thinking.
So with that,
I don't know whether we still have about 10 minutes,
we still can take one or two questions.
Yeah,
we can do the carry over your way.
How do you think about technologies that are,
I'm sure of by their very nature,
less accessible?
So I'm thinking of things like ar and Vr,
which is very visual or,
um,
like voice,
uh,
voice assistance,
which obviously wouldn't work very well for people with hearing impairment.
Uh,
things like that.
I,
I personally think that,
um,
there will be,
there will be a convergence of a different technology coming together to
multimodal kind of experience.
And,
um,
it's,
it's not to say for a specific,
a function that you,
let's say it's a,
it's a,
VR is a completely visual,
right?
But even that you can use,
for example,
um,
uh,
machine learning or artificial intelligence to interpret the scene,
um,
for the person who cannot see.
So one of the,
for example,
one of the biggest,
um,
piece of work this knee is working on is used to be that when you go see a
movie,
um,
if you are blind,
you cannot,
obviously you cannot see,
right?
So they have audio description of the scene.
So if you'd done in novel for audio description of scenery,
one can imagine that can be captured,
right?
You can,
you can digitize that and that you begin to be,
to develop a repository and that,
so that even as you develop with the virtual reality kind of either games
experience in or whatever,
you can still have voice,
you know,
uh,
over.
So you can use the technologies,
um,
kind of efficiency and cost effective in the fad factor to begin to integrate,
uh,
multiple,
um,
multiple technology together.
So in the beginning it could be a single thread,
but I think if you design and thinking that you want to be pervasively
assessable,
then may start engaging other technology to,
to compliment that.
Does that make sense?
Yup.
Okay.
I landed,
thank Francis for this very insightful and inspiring presentation.
[inaudible].